allies what allies that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now whenever biden meets with world
leaders especially when he's over in
europe you know america is going to get
taken to the cleaners one way or another
and today was no exception
during his meeting with the g7 okay this
is what went down first before biden
even showed up
america got lectured by several of our
so-called allies so it was france canada
and the uk they felt the need to respond
to the supreme court's decision to
overturn roe versus wade with very sharp
criticism
now for boris johnson who has
single-handedly destroyed the tory party
joining the dog pile on the u.s for him
oh that's really rich because he didn't
tell you that the united kingdom in many
ways has tighter restrictions on
abortion than many states in the united
states because they require two doctors
to sign off on an abortion in the uk
now boris's critique is a transparent
effort to bolster biden and to appear
as a unifier in pushing for more ukraine
aid good luck and unifying anyone on
that
now this isn't the first time nor will
likely be the last that our allies in
name only have expressed strong
opposition to america's conservative
populist movement that ben was just
referencing now they hated trump of
course for a lot of reasons but chief
among them
was his demand that europe spent more on
their military after decades of
essentially what was free riding on the
united states
when you remember back on trump when he
would uh go over there he was pretty
pragmatic he was unabashedly
pro-american and he was consistently
blunt
those are three qualities the europeans
generally loathe about us
now europeans preferred presidents who
bad mouth or apologize for america first
obama
in america there's a failure to
appreciate europe's leading role in the
world america has shown arrogance
and been dismissive
even derisive our country still
struggles with the legacies
of
slavery and segregation
the past treatment of native americans
we've at times been disengaged and at
times we sought to dictate our terms
now he was embarrassed by us and he
didn't care that his slamming of america
to world leaders gave us less leverage
and hurt our moral standing on critical
issues
and his talking america down routine has
only gotten worse with the current
occupant of the white house
the american experiment
in democracy
is in a danger
like it hasn't been in my lifetime
it's in danger this hour
the anti-voter laws that many states
have passed are part of an intentional
effort to exclude americans from
participating in our democracy there's
corruption here at home
especially when it comes to how people
pay taxes
or rather how they don't
racism
the ugly poison that has long haunted
and plagued our nation
a racist nation that also hates women if
we can still use that word woman now
remember biden also believes our supreme
court now is misogynist another great
message for our children and the world
it's a realization of an extreme
ideology so extreme the women and girls
were forced to bear their rapist
child
now hearing all this of course of course
european leaders wouldn't think twice
about jumping in the scrum to slam the
court do it as well i mean biden's doing
it why can't they
and even think it was perfectly fine to
make our taxpayers foot the lion's share
of the bill for this pointless war at
this point in ukraine
because when they all agree today that
they are unanimous that the alliance
will support ukraine for the long haul
i'll tell you what that means that means
that americans should be prepared to
fund a disproportionate share of the war
efforts for years
bynes national security advisor
apparently thinks money grows on trees
and he's seen reports
i've seen the reports of
specific details around advanced air
defense capabilities that the united
states is preparing to provide to the
ukrainians i can confirm that we are in
fact
in the process of finalizing a package
that includes advanced air defense
capabilities okay this is complete
madness ukraine is losing the war
and biden has no idea what he's doing
and who trusts millie in austin i don't
now back in may congress approved a
staggering 40 billion dollar ukraine aid
package which included five billion
dollars and what we were told congress
assured us was emergency food assistance
to the area's hardest hit
they were hardest hit by the way for
starvation that was the risk they were
facing due to the conflict and all the
agriculture lost
but according to politico today more
than a month after congress approved
that emergency measure usaid and the
bide administration have yet to send out
any of the funds
even as president joe biden and his top
officials increase their public warnings
about the war's impact on food prices
and growing world hunger in in various
speeches and at the g7 meetings
okay
the guy
who can't handle 5 billion
thinks he should be trusted with
mobilizing
600 billion dollars
think of the potential for waste fraud
and abuse there especially since biden
is betting on a trifecta a globalist
greeniac dei fantasy
collectively we aim to mobilize nearly
600 billion dollars from the g7 by 2027.
these strategic investments are areas of
critical
to sustainable development and to our
shared global stability
health
and health security
digital
connectivity gender equality and equity
climate and energy security
that's a socialist mouthful isn't it why
are they all wearing creepy costumes all
the same
now when biden says collectively as he
did just there and he wants to mobilize
the 600 billion who do you think is
going to pick up most of that tab
you that's who but don't worry because
our allies are cheering biden as he also
sells out u.s manufacturing
the u.s government just facilitated a
new partnership between two american
firms and the government of angola
to invest two billion dollars in
building the new solar projects in
angola
it's a partnership that will help angola
meet its climate goals
of course our allies are thrilled about
all of this after all
you america you have a lot to atone for
especially under trump when our economy
was far outpacing europe's remember we
were energy independent wages were
rising no inflation families could
actually go on vacation
people were pretty optimistic
that made the elites especially the euro
elites absolutely miserable
if americans could be so free and
prosperous it was only a matter of time
before their own people demanded better
results from them in europe
just look at the trouble macron is
having now
thus of course they recoiled at america
first they prefer america apologetic
biden's going to give him anything they
want and they're going to he's going to
ask zero in return just how they like it
the time has come for republicans to ask
themselves which countries are truly
allies of the united states and which
are only allies of the democratic party
because if the purpose of this alliance
is to promote abortion climate mandates
and endless pointless spending on wars
how can we ask american soldiers many of
whom by the way are devoutly religious
to fight and possibly die for it
for that matter if our allies are only
willing to help the democrats but never
the republicans
why should republicans in congress fund
this alliance at all
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else